let's move forward to the next part of
Malay speech which is digging into why
the West is in
Jeopardy now if free market capitalism
and economic freedom have been
remarkable instruments to eradicate
poverty globally and we are presently
experiencing the most favorable period
in human history it is worth inquiring
why I assert that the West is in
Jeopardy the main problem of the West
today is that we not only have to
confront those who even after the fall
of the wall and overwhelming evidence
continue to advocate for impoverishing
socialism but also our own leaders
thinkers and academics who sheltered in
a misguided framework undermine the
foundations of the system that has given
us the greatest wealth and prosperity in
our
history the theoretical framework I am
referring to is neoclassical economic
the issue with neoclassicals is that
since the model they they fell in love
with doesn't match reality they
attribute the error to the supposed
market failure instead of revising the
premises of their Model Market is not
just a graphical description of a supply
curve and a demand curve on a
graph the market is a mechanism of
social cooperation where property rights
are voluntarily
exchanged thus considering this
definition discussing market failure is
a contradiction in
terms there is no market failure if
transactions are voluntary the only
situation in which there can be a market
failure is if there is coercion present
and the only one with the ability to
coers in a generalized manner is the
state that possesses the Monopoly of
violence each time you want to correct a
presumed market failure inevitably due
to not knowing the market or because you
have become attached to a failed model
you are opening doors to socialism and
condemning people to
Poverty so this is where he's going
right to the heart of what the WF is all
about they're they're not the WF is not
a leftist organization it is I don't
know a neoliberal or you know he calls
neoclassical um where they Embrace
markets on the whole but uh they see
lots of market failures and say that you
know there's a there's a a need for a
strong robust government interv ition to
deal with those market failures things
like uh you know pollution climate
change the government needs to intervene
and Malay is saying no you're wrong
Davos crowd uh and we're gonna do things
a different way in Argentina is that
more or less are we on on the same page
with like our interpretations
here um I think so yeah um I think you
know he he who was definitely criticized
uh
because of this part because of the part
where he says that there can be no
market failure you know by neoclassical
economists in Argentina uh just because
they well of course they claim that they
are and I think the phrasing could have
been differently in that um people
individually can definitely fail in the
market it's just that you know uh
there's nothing that's that that can be
systemic that cannot be solved by the
market itself uh but but you know in
other than that I think um I think your
interpretation is right and I think you
know what m is saying is again is very
similar to what we have been hearing um
in Argentina it's just at this time you
know because it was in Davos it caught
you know people's eye all over the world
um so and I'm very glad that I did
because otherwise it would have been
just us you know uh listening to to his
preaching if you will um but but but now
it's all it's also you so do you
consider him to be a sort of like high
priest of Argentine libertarianism like
what do you think of the sort of proz do
you like it do you find it creepy do you
fear that he'll develop this Cult of
Personality in the same way that many
other leaders throughout Argentine
history have um I'm I'm I'm a bit afraid
of that Cult of Personality because I
think many people follow him you know
and and not the libertarian ideas uh
that he preaches again um and and I
think that can be that could be bad in
case things go wrong for example if he
doesn't deliver uh because then people
who follow him will not be able to
criticize him whenever he fails you know
whenever he does something that's wrong
um many people today for example I see
that they that they they don't want to
criticize the government because of
anything even if they make mistakes you
know uh just because they wna they want
to support meay all the way
I don't think that's that's very healthy
um because that can lead him to believe
that he can you know do whatever um I do
believe of course he's a Libertarian and
I I have confidence I mean I voted for
him like all the times you know in the
primaries and the general election in
the runoff and I would vote for him
again um but I want him to you know be
uh faithful you know to to the
libertarian idea uh in that regard I
think he was more like a priest when he
was campaigning again he's not talking
much right now I think that's very
strategic I think he has definitely
adapted to being president which is a
good thing because there was this you
know concern that that sack was talking
about earlier that he would be you know
like Trump and he would just keep
talking um as president all the time and
and doing nothing um but mle is not one
of those um I think he is like
strategically receding you know from the
public high as the nasty you know job
gets done basically uh because of course
you know raising revenue for the
government is something that you know
would be Unthinkable under a Libertarian
government but again his priority now is
to stabilize the country you know avoid
hyperinflation and then you know um
transform the country um so I think
that's why he's not talking much but he
can if things you know turn right for
him if he is able to deliver if if this
law that he's um sending out Congress
gets passed and and we start to see a
recovery you know an economic recovery
in future months I think he can be he
can go back to the you know to the
priest role uh from which he has receded
in recent
months it's it's going to be interesting
because he's staking out such this is a
very doctrin libertarian position that
really differentiates him from the kind
of more
liberal governance that the WF would
suggest where he's saying literally
there's no such thing as a market
failure um you know this I uh and and so
it's kind of like where the policy
rubber meets the road for a Libertarian
because there will be situations
where uh some sort of voluntary
transaction results in uh an externality
it results in something that costs other
people something and kind of the the
doctrinaire libertarian approach to that
as well they should be compensated
through they should be able to bring a
suit they should be able to bring a Tor
through the courts and get compensated
for that um that's not at all how the
modern world is governed we're governed
via regulation to uh avoid those that
that kind of extreme liability from like
an oil spill or um air pollution or
something like that so it's G to be I
think an where're it's like something to
watch and kind of like empirically
observe hey thanks for watching that
clip from our new show just asking
questions you can watch another clip
here or the full episode here new
episodes drop every week so subscribe to
reent TV's YouTube channel to get
notified when that happens or to the
just asking questions podcast on Apple
Spotify or any other podc see you next
week